-Well, it's Thanksgiving,
so you know what that means.
America's crazy
uncle Mike Lindell is
at the dinner table,
screaming at the top
of his lungs about voter fraud,
while everyone else
silently ignores him
and tucks into their
green bean casserole.
Oh, and also, President Biden
tried to talk to a turkey.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
If you did have
some turkey today,
it almost certainly wasn't one
of these guys
because they were both pardoned
by President Biden on Monday.
And Biden could not help
indulge in some, let's say,
overcooked Thanksgiving puns.
-First of all, the votes are in.
They've been counted
and verified.
There's no ballot stuffing.
There's no fowl play.
[ Laughter ]
The only red wave this season
is going to be
a German Shepherd,
Commander,
who knocks over the cranberry
sauce on our table.
[ Laughter ]
Interesting fact --
every one of those puns came
from a book called...
[ Laughter ]
I do forgive him
because he's a grandpa.
He's President Grandpa
and he's been a grandpa so long,
his granddaughter
just got married,
which means,
if Biden wins a second term,
there's a chance he could be
President Great-Grandpa,
and that would be the first time
in American history
that's happened.
Or the fifth.
I don't know.
I tried to Google it.
I couldn't figure it out.
[ Laughter ]
I entered in...
...and Google just said,
"Do you really need to know?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Not really."
And Google said,
"Just come back when you have
something important.
Do you know how many searches
we do in a day?"
[ Laughter ]
Point is Biden's jokes were bad,
but I'll happily take
some stale puns
over a long rant about how China
is working with Hugo Chávez
to smuggle in forged ballots
or whatever Trump used to talk
about during holidays.
[ As Trump ]
They've treated me
very unkindly,
these crooked Democrats,
maybe worse than anyone
has ever been treated before,
and that, of course,
is the true meaning
of Mother's Day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Remember when he used
to host the Easter Egg Roll
at the White House and...
[ Laughter ]
...the bunny would just stand
next to him
for what felt like forever,
while Trump would ramble
to children
about how he rebuilt
the military or something?
[ Laughter ]
And, for some reason,
that bunny was always
making a face
like he just walked in
on his parents having sex.
[ Laughter ]
Which, presumably,
happens all the time because,
you know, they are bunnies.
"Mom, Dad!
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm already sharing my room
with 30 brothers and sisters!"
In fairness to Trump,
I don't know why
his staff went on Amazon
and specifically chose
the costume called...
[ Laughter ]
I did enjoy Biden's shout-out
to his dog Commander, though.
That one doesn't quite seem
like a joke to me.
[ As Biden ]
There's no red wave,
unless Commander knocks over
the cranberry sauce.
I'm serious, folks,
he might do it.
[ Laughter ]
That dog is crazy!
I'm scared to death of him.
[ Laughter ]
Last, Thanksgiving,
he jumped out
and grabbed the carving knife,
held off the Secret Service
[ Laughter ]
for an hour.
They had to throw a net
over him!
There's also a decent chance
I fell asleep
on the Acela and dreamed that.
[ Laughter ]
No, it happened.
For the most part, it was
a very traditional ceremony.
Although,
there was one odd moment,
where Biden asked the providers
of the turkeys
how many more they had,
made a weird joke
about visiting other countries,
and then asked the turkey
if it wanted to talk.
-How many turkeys you got
down there?
You're raising?
-circle Range grows
about 9.5 million turkeys
a year.
-God love you,
Nine and a half million turkeys.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
I tell you what.
That's like some of the
countries I've been to.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And the --
Anyway.
Do you want to talk?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-Wait.
How?
[ Laughter ]
How is that like some of the
countries you've been to?
[ Laughter ]
They had that many people
or they had that many turkeys?
No wonder you tried
to get the turkey
to say something
to change the subject.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Bail me out here, brother.
[ Laughter and applause ]
With that said, asking a turkey
if they want to talk
into a microphone is very funny.
[ Laughter ]
Mostly because it's just fun
to imagine what a turkey
would say.
Would it be like
an Emmy acceptance speech?
"I just want to thank my family
my friends,
my agent, my manager.
Everybody down at the roost
who believed in me.
And I want to say
to my kids at home,
Jeremy and Delilah, go to bed!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, it is a nice change
of pace
that the president is willing
to share the mic.
You know Trump would never share
the spotlight with two turkeys,
unless he was posing
for a family photo.
[ Turkey gobbling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
They do puff their chests out
like they're turkeys.
But, as you heard
in that first clip,
Biden couldn't help
but take a slight jab
at the supposed red wave
that never materialized
in this year's midterms.
Many people,
including Republicans,
are still wondering why
that red wave never happened
and at least one GOP pundit
on Fox News had a theory.
-We have a candidate
quality problem,
but what we've seen is
a real intensification
of this problem
from top to bottom --
not just Senate candidates,
but House candidates,
secretary of state candidates,
and governors, and the like.
And it's, you know, what I call
the MyPillowization
of the Republican Party,
[ Laughter ]
is we've attracted
these more cartoon characters
and if somebody speaking
at a rally with a president
or a presidential candidate
is best known
as a pillow salesman,
run to high heaven.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you can run,
but you can't hide
from Mike Lindell's voice.
It doesn't matter
how far away you are,
you will still be able
to hear him.
It's like that scene
from "Jurassic Park."
If, at any point, you see
the water in your glass
rippling, don't worry.
It just means Mike Lindell
is speaking somewhere.
[ Laughter ]
But if Republicans are worried
about the MyPillowization
of their party,
then they're probably not going
to be thrilled
to hear the latest news
from Mike Lindell Land.
But, in a way, we are
because here's the thing.
It's Thanksgiving and just
as important as the turkey
and the stuffing
and the football
are the crazy uncles.
And, just in time
for Thanksgiving,
old uncle Mike went on one
of his usual,
obscure right-wing TV shows
that you can only get
with rabbit ears or a ham radio
and claimed he had solid proof
that elections
across the country were stolen
from Republicans.
-We have cyberevidence
of a 37,000-vote flip
on the Kari Lake race
on Thursday after the election.
We have all the Edison data
that came in, in real time,
that came through
on all the races,
including Finchem,
Blake Masters.
They all won, okay?
They all won.
This is like we were watching
from every angle.
You go up to Michigan,
they've completely wiped out
the state of Michigan,
stole the legislatures,
everything.
-Mm-hmm.
Other races, from Oz.
Oz really won.
There's all these
different races.
But they were caught, so.
But Arizona is the gateway
to all of our --
to expose everything, everybody.
We have to --
We have to get Arizona.
They need to do
a new election.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right,
they need to do a new election.
He screams like he's
doing dialogue
from a straight-to-DVD knockoff
of "Back to the Future."
[ As Lindell ]
Marty, we got to go back in time
and do a new election.
I hooked up the DeLorean
to the clock tower
and got electrocuted
and that's why I talk like this.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I found
that Sports Almanac
and bet a million dollars on
Da Bears!
[ Laughter ]
Now, you might be wondering why
we're spending any time
at all talking
about a pillow salesman.
Well, aside from the fact
that it's Thanksgiving
and we're celebrating
the importance of crazy uncles,
Lindell has also been
a major influence
within the election
denial movement.
As we noted before,
he's endorsed candidates,
appeared at Trump rallies,
and, according
to The New York Times,
he spent...
First of all, I don't believe
he has researchers.
I believe he has guys
who are willing
to say they did research, just
to collect an easy paycheck.
[ As Lindell ]
Alright, gang, did you guys do
all the research I asked for?
"Uh, yeah, definitely.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
we found a bunch
of cyberevidence
[ Laughter ]
using the, uh, Edison data
to prove that they, uh,
completely wiped out
the state of Michigan?"
Sounds good, fellas.
Here's a million dollars.
[ Laughter ]
Now, if you ever hear
Lindell yelling,
just grab a lab coat
and go get paid.
Also, how does
he have this much money?
His pillows can be that good.
Otherwise,
he wouldn't always look like
he hasn't slept in five years.
[ Laughter ]
But I don't know.
Maybe they are.
I don't know.
So, let me try one.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
I will say,
doesn't look that bad.
[ Clang ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
No. [Indistinct]
[ Clang ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Fresh laughter and applause ]
Why did we move our sound
effects guy to Australia?
[ Laughter ]
We're going to get this one.
[ Clang ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay, you guys, I want
to make something clear.
This is not a real MyPillow!
I do not want to get sued
by Mike Lindell because,
if I am, I think I would laugh
through the whole trial
and the jury would turn
against me for being immature.
If you want to sue someone,
sue Sal. He writes these.
I barely know what any
of these words mean.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clang ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Lindell is also --
[ Laughter ]
Lindell is also currently banned
from Twitter, as of this taping,
but he's been very public
about the fact
that he wants his account back.
In fact, he even issued
a direct plea
to Twitter's new owner,
Elon Musk.
-My shout-out to Elon Musk
would be, you know,
if your site should be a new
platform of free speech,
but yet, you're going
to carve out the guys that talk
about our election crimes
and our election integrity,
I don't think it's
that free, Steve.
I think it's --
I think I would like to do
a shout-out
to Elon Musk right now.
Hey, check out the evidence.
I was banned because I was
telling the truth.
-Would you commit, right now,
to do an open live Twitter
with Elon Musk
about what you believe is
the voter fraud related
to machines and other things
in the 2020 election, sir?
-Absolutely.
I'd fly to him,
do whatever it takes.
And I would do that any day,
anytime,
any time of day or night,
and I'll drop everything I have
to do that.
-Alright, first of all, dude,
you're on TV.
Wear something nicer
than a plaid shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Second of all...
[ Applause ]
Seriously.
Be a professional.
[ Laughter ]
Second of all, you don't need
to call it a shout-out.
Everything you say
is a shout-out.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, now that we've had
our fun, let's remember
that it's Thanksgiving.
It's a time for us to come
together with our friends,
our families,
and our communities,
to spend time with another,
to give thanks,
and, of course,
to ignore our crazy uncles.
And, if you have a crazy uncle
at Thanksgiving this year,
don't worry.
Just remember the first rule --
whatever you do,
do not turn to them and say...
-Do you want to talk?
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]